is there some general things that are
really powerful in terms of you said
nation religion those are groups
yeah can you group people nicely
in helping you understand human nature
so
group them into nations based on their
citizenry
that's geography right
the geographic location of your birth
or your uh long-term residence or maybe
religious belief well you what religion
you believe over time
is there groups like that and then
race
is that
useful
what are the pros and cons of looking at
outcomes based on
these kinds of groups
race in particular
i think they're pros and i think they're
cons i mean i am myself glenn lowery
sits before you right now
a black american an african american i i
quote unquote i identify as you know
that's the way they talk about it
nowadays i identify as a black american
my skin is brown
my hair is coarse
my nose is broad
uh relative to the way other people's
noses look my lips are thicker
that's a consequence of my
ancestral descent
from the human population
resident in the african continent in
millennia past
my race
here in the united states we have
various quote unquote races
defined crudely in the way that i just
tried to define myself
you could say and i think there is a
very powerful argument that these are
superficial differences
i mean
really why should it matter that your
eye color
or your hair color
or the shape of the bones in your face
or the color the tone of your skin the
amount of melon and how it is that you
react to ultraviolet radiation in terms
of your
skin
what is that
to bait the basis of anything i mean
that's arbitrary that's not meaningful
could there really be meaning in these
superficial differences among human
beings isn't that a
archaic or barbaric way of thinking
about ourselves to
look at each other's skin color or hair
texture and then to decide oh that's a
black or that's a white or that's a
latin or that's an asian or that's a
whatever
that that's
something that we should outgrow
a person might say
that's a relic of a kind of tribal
society of a kind of pre-modern
society where
we built real
structure on the basis of such
superficial
difference a person could say that
on the other hand i
am
a black american i mean that's part of
my
identity that's part of my
heritage it's part of the
stories that i tell myself about
who my people are
why do i need a people why do i need a
narrative of
dissent
in which i affiliate with
a
racially defined people do i really need
that i mean i think that's an important
question i i in fact
this is a confession
think of myself as black i could
think of myself as simply human i could
not identify specifically as black i
could i could say
my eyes are brown too so what i'm a
brown eye i mean you know i'm going to
invent a group based on my eye color um
i weigh 290 pounds i'm gonna have a body
size group i'm a plus 200 and that's
quote who i am close quote i don't do
that
i came from chicago yes i do have a
certain sense of affinity with my
hometown i'm a chicago-born
person but frankly i haven't lived in
chicago since 1979.
that's a long time
uh i wear my chicago origins very very
lightly
i would not go to war with someone from
cleveland or st louis
and fight to the death with that
st louis person or that cleveland person
based upon the fact that we come from
different cities and you have even
abandoned in your heart the chicago
bulls there's some chicago that's still
in me i suppose but it's not it's not
very deep it it's not quote who i am uh
anymore and i'm wondering uh i hear i'm
trying to pose a question why is it that
being
a descendant of african slaves should be
who i am so there's some answers
one answer is
people will look at me and deal with me
differently based upon what they see
i don't have control over that
i'm going to be perceived as a member of
a group whether or not i elect to
affiliate myself with that group
or not
therefore
i need to be mindful of the fact that
regardless of what my internal
orientation is
the world will perceive me in a
particular way and will perceive me
differently based upon the color of my
skin so a police officer who stops me at
two o'clock in the morning because my
tail light is out
and ask me for my
automobile registration and i reach
quickly to the glove compartment
to get my registration
and the police officer says show me your
hands
and i don't quite hear what he says or i
ignore what he says is i'm getting my
document out of my glove compartment but
the police officer thinks because i have
not responded
to his demand to show my hands that i
might be reaching for a weapon
and the police officer sees that i'm
black and fears that the likelihood that
i might have a weapon is higher because
in that town at that time
a lot of the people who get stopped with
weapons in their car happen to be
black and male and so on and he pulls
his weapon and he discharges it and i'm
bleeding out there and i'm dead now and
i all of that is a possibility that's
very real and it's based upon the color
of my skin and therefore
when he stops me i keep my hands on the
steering wheel and i don't go to the
glove compartment and i'm fearful of the
fact that he might
mistake me for a criminal etc
or i walk into a high-end uh store
clothing store i see you're nicely
dressed there
uh i'm not but that's okay
i i do have some good clothes at home i
just didn't wear them here today yeah uh
but you know what i mean and the clothes
the the salesman in the clothing store
uh either
treats me like uh you know an old friend
and is warm and welcoming and what can i
do for you sir and let me show you this
and that and what are you looking for
and what because he thinks i'm going to
spend a thousand dollars there that day
and he's going to get a 5 commission or
whatever it is and you know he either
does that or he ignores me and looks at
me with suspicion and thinks i might be
trying to shoplift something or thinks
i'm only going to spend 50 and not 500
and therefore i'm not worth his time
and i'm aware of the fact that when i go
into the clothing store especially the
high-end places where i can buy some buy
a good suit or you know buy some really
good dress shirts or slacks that fit me
well and so on i'm aware of the fact
that i may not be taken seriously by the
salesman based upon the fact that he's
looking at me and he sees
a black person and therefore
um
i dress up before i go to go out to buy
clothes to get you know because i want
to present myself as not someone who
just walked in off the street but as one
of those black people who is really
prepared to spend some money in the
store so that i can be treated with
respect and i have to carry the burden
such as it is
of knowing that i need to earn
the uh
being taken seriously
by overcoming the suppositions that
people may have about me based upon the
color
of my skin
something like that
or i ask myself
what am i going to teach my children
about who they are and where they come
from what stories am i going to tell
them
about their ancestors who are their
ancestors
every african-american has european
ancestors every black person in the
united states of america
i think i can say that almost without
exception
we could go to 23andme and look at the
dna
they have european ancestors they're not
purely african
uh that's a fact and that's a
consequence of the
experience of african descended people
because it's a mixed population
my name is lowry
spelled l-o-u-r-y but pronounced as if
it were l-o-w-e-r-y
and uh i gather if you trace the history
of that name that it's uh scottish
so somewhere you could identify as a
scot all right well or i could claim
some scottish descent
but i don't i don't know who those
ancestors are and frankly i don't know
who my enslaved ancestors
are i i can't trace my family history
back
very far
into the 19th century
um but so what what stories do i tell my
children about who we are about who
their ancestors are i mean i want to
tell my children some story and that
story is going to be colored
quote unquote
by
my race
so even though it is superficial
and in an ideal world you might think
why would human beings
i mean i read science fiction so there's
this chinese writer chiksan liu is his
name i might not pronounce it exactly
right c-i-x-i-n
l-i-u chickson lu he has a trilogy uh
the three-body problem
the dark forest
and death's end those are the three
books of chicks and lou's trilogy about
how try solaris
which is another star system within a
few light light years of the solar
system
and earth
get into a conflict
and when the tricelerians come down
to dominate earth
suddenly all of these differences
between the chinese and the north
americans and the europeans and the
africans and the south asians
become kind of insignificant because
after all the tricelerians with their
advanced civilization
whose star system is dying
have their eyes on the solar system
which has a planet the third rock from
the sun that is pretty habitable and
you know the difference between us
become pretty insignificant
so
we shouldn't need
for an invasion by extraterrestrial
beings
to have to happen
before we would recognize the common
humanity that we all share
that is profound
and is deep we all descend in effect
from the same ancestral population of
homo sapiens who walked out of east
africa eons ago
and has
survived amongst all of the different
possible
you know variations of species and
whatnot of humanoid
population homo sapiens have flourished
the others have died out
uh and here we are and and you know we
can just look at the genetic endowments
that characterize our biological
essence and we can see that uh
we are all quote unquote the same
beneath the skin and yet
we end up
uh freighting so much weight
onto these superficial differences so i
can i can see both sides of the
issue is what i'm saying i can see the
argument race is an irrelevancy
because
at the end of the day
deep down it is
but i can also see the argument
that i hold on to racial identity
because a
my racial presentation colors how other
people
deal with me but b
because everybody needs a story
you know everybody needs an account you
tell me you're jewish i mean i don't
know how deep that is i don't know how
genetically profound that is i do know
that it's a culturally
profound
identity for a lot of people
uh based upon maybe some of the same
kind of forces that i'm talking about a
they won't let you not be jewish
you could say you're not jewish but when
hitler is rounding people up
what you say doesn't have a whole lot to
do with
the with what the gestapo was about
and b you need to tell your children a
story
you